phoned I need you back I never left a
new poster dropped for the new Bond
movie no time to die and to be honest it
didn't say much but that's why we're
here to tell you everything you need to
know about James Bond's
25th film right now on ketchup the
ketchup the new poster came out on
October 5th which was official James
Bond day celebrating 57 years since the
certified fresh' doctor know was
released on that same day in 1962 but as
Facebook follower Xavier pointed out the
latest release from the bond 25
marketing team is a quote disappointing
poster for an awesome title the 25th
installment of the double-oh-seven
franchise should hit theaters on April
8th of next year but that date has
changed more times than my relationship
status the past couple years so who
really knows I wish I could help what we
do know is that Daniel Craig is
returning for his fifth and final turn
as James Bond which is nice to hear
considering he told Time Out London back
in 2015 that he would rather quote break
this glass and slash my wrists and play
Bond again thankfully that did not
happen everyone and he is back it's
amazing what 25 million dollars can do
he'll be squaring off against Oscar
winner rami malek who assured fans via
video message in April that he is up for
the challenge of being the next Bond
villain I will be making sure Mr Bond
does not have an easy ride of it in this
his 25th outing his voice is so
naturally evil sounding it's insane the
cast will also include familiar faces
like ray Fiennes Jeffrey Wright Lea
Seydoux and Naomi Harris all reprising
their roles from past Bond films and
interestingly enough Christoph Waltz is
spotted on set during filming fueling
speculation that his Spectre character
Blofeld we'll be back with unfinished
business another actor that was
basically born play a villain I mean if
I met him I'd be scared in real life
and other new cast members include Blade
Runner 2049 xana-do Tomas and Captain
Marvel breakout star leshawna Lynch her
character's name will be know me and
will reportedly get the codename
double-oh-seven after bond retires so
forget the edger sell the discussion and
let the female James Bond rumors fly
doesn't fly now part of the reason the
release date has been pushed back a
couple times now is that the original
director Oscar winner Danny Boyle left
in August of 2018 citing creative
differences he was replaced by cary
fukunaga best known for certified fresh'
hits like beasts of no nation and maniac
on netflix plus HBO's true detective
season one which was by far the fans
favorite season with an audience score
of 97% and definitely worth noting is
that the script writing team includes
the one and only Phoebe Waller bridge I
mean along with cleaning up at the Emmys
last month for her show fleabag Phoebe
is also a creative force behind another
hit series killing Eve so adding her to
the team was a no brainer can I put in a
request for a hot priest in this movie
the priest is quite a haul so as far as
applied details go we know that bond
will not be on active service when the
film starts instead he's gonna be
chilling in Jamaica which is where this
cool behind-the-scenes video was shot
that came out in June so bond will come
out of retirement when Jeffery writes
felix leiter character comes seeking his
help in rescuing a kidnapped scientist
and hunting down a villain with a deadly
new technology the names bond James Bond
Daniel Craig's past Bond films have had
an interesting pattern on the tomato
meter 2006 certified fresh' Casino
Royale was followed up by Quantum of
Solace which scored 65% then came the
certified fresh' Skyfall followed up by
Spectre which has 63 percent so if
history repeats itself like a good
chicken martini no time to die could
have certified fresh' potential written
all over it
what are you doing alright but it is
time to kick it over to you now are you
excited for bond 25 in one more Bond
movie with Daniel Craig or are you ready
to move on from the craig era let us
know all your thoughts and feelings in
the comment section and if you liked
this episode and you want to see more I
know you do subscribe and click that
Bell icon as always thanks for watching
the ketchup I'm not surprised and I'll
see you next time
you
[Music]
[Music]